lo que era reconocido hace más de 150
años se celebró por primera vez este 19
de junio como un feriado a nivel
nacional con desfiles música y baile los
estadounidenses conmemoraron el jumping
la fecha que recuerda el 19 de junio de
1865 cuando se le avisó a los últimos
afroamericanos esclavizados en galveston
texas que habían sido liberados dos años
atrás por orden del entonces presidente
abraham lincoln
es importante que sea un día festivo
porque reconoce las luchas y la
perseverancia de nuestros antepasados y
ese día de la libertad para ellos el de
este año tiene mayor peso se da pocos
días después de que el presidente joe
biden lo convirtiera en un festivo
federal y justo un año después de la
muerte de georg floyd el afroamericano
que perdió la vida bajo custodia
policial y desató el movimiento contra
el racismo más grande del siglo 21 como
parte de las celebraciones una estatua
de georges lloyd fue presentada en
brooklyn
y esta estatua transmite la fuerza y la
dignidad de georges floyd esperó que
impulse a los electores los residentes y
los transeúntes a continuar
organizándose movilizándose marchando y
educándose con el objetivo de un cambio
activo
james el jumping como feriado nacional
supone un espaldarazo para la comunidad
afro en eeuu pero no borra el hecho de
que aún quedan muchas batallas por
librar sobre todo en términos de
igualdad